Okay.
Let us know in the comments
if you know where my keys are.
I am locked out of my apartment
and my landlord said
I cannot sleep
in the hallway again.
And cut.
Great job, guys.
I missed most of the show,
because there's free pizza
in the conference room.
Oh yeah, Ryan, I can only assume
that your knees were too pointy.
Again, so smooth them out
somehow. That's it.
Is there still pizza?
I mean, yeah,
but you better hurry.
You know how people get around
here when there's free pizza.
Oh yeah.
Oh my god.
I'm telling HR.
This is why I pack
a lunch, bitch.
Hit him!
Nate? I'm the boss now.
Also, dude, culturally
insensitive costume.
My eyes. I can't see.
Sticky note! I can't see!
Oh, ow.
There it is.
The conference room.
Ew, all that's left is veggie.
Gross, never mind.
Anybody seen Name tag Tay?
He loves veggie.